hey what's happening is your boys head
is my life become oh and but what am I
please kill me
welcome to ultimate battle simulator
ss-sorry ultimate epic battle simulator
this is why you clicked on this channel
isn't it because we want action hardcore
[Music]
badassery and epicness
hey guys to be tech here and today I'm
going to show you how to mine so fast
that you can't even dig a straight hole
so in this game me for you for some
reason aren't familiar with this yeah
you can simulate where's what came about
you can generate war now I have a pretty
strong community it could run roblox on
max settings so let's see what we can do
next hundred and six Nazis and another
six and another and another
that's how many Nazis versus one table
[Music]
oh my god yes no it's not lagging at all
what I got for FPS going in that is a
lot of [ __ ] Nazis oh Jesus Christ and
maybe I shouldn't have picked so many
got a solid 60 FPS going on here well
maybe I shouldn't have made something
you know maybe I exaggerated just a
little bit with this whole table istic
oh my gosh how many did I make this
[ __ ] do
I got two FPS let the battle begin go
fast by Nazi you kill the table I don't
know it's an evolution I don't know
what's happening but I'm sure it's
pretty epic I think I just nuked all the
Nazis I don't know I have one framerate
maybe let's let's exit okay let's try
that again
okay oh Jesus Christ I had 650 pick up
let's just remove one mmm all right
let's remove one of them and then we can
see maybe don't act okay here we go
yeah that's a lot better well now we
have a decent framerate
there you go nasty
all right okay
a lotta nothing they're very angry
they're very angry at the table where is
table there is go table you can do it
riggan no cable no time aw damn it
an equal amount of table as there are
German soldiers tonight we dine in on
table as they said I feel like I need to
have an epic battle speech to my table
my fellow tables
we've come this far to fight for our
freedom those Nazi scum those filthy
German I bet they was pulling back those
sense objective we will not let him dine
upon it we will not let them not you no
sir they do not respect what they do not
respect the hard surface of a nicely
polished word and Gable that's what
Oh Jason thank the spring okay mom bye
dammit they built a field yeah
oh my god the nastika fighting strong
but they have no match against disabled
I can leave the table to getting rekt no
I possess the table hold your line table
oh you're mad you're out table
not today they're getting [ __ ] great
this is so [ __ ] [ __ ] long ago the
Four Nations lived together in harmony
then everything changed I guess now we
know if they bunch of Nazis fought
against a budget table Nazis would win
okay do you really know tit let's make
it a little bit more interesting all
right the will happen we'll have table
over here all right we'll have dressers
fighting tables and then here we'll have
one chuck norris will have 200 santa
clauses 250 catapult 250 zombie and one
dwarf my gosh here we go
all right we got a table hoorah hoorah
table okay both come on
my money's on table I don't know about
you brother
I don't know why your breath vs. dresser
that filthy disgusting despicable
breakfast I bet they don't even dress
themselves I bet their mamas versus a
bunch of [ __ ] catapult yeah they're
probably going to win burst from the
other corner and your car that's right
ho ho ho going to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
but it's Chuck nearest where we think
the man to miss the ladies every yes you
look Haley penguin you look angry
looking like birthday that works okay
[ __ ] it
and that [ __ ] zombies out of my let
go
all right director that are moving in
they seem a bit confused but they're
fighting they're getting aggressive
they're getting wrecked by the catapult
tables are standing frogs against
Antigone but that regard that not like
table no they do not they are [ __ ]
them tables up oh but he looks like
stepped off we got the greater than uh
Gil dezer said racers no kill session my
god who would make Santa Claus our
tables
pretend of course and fighting thought
but thank you they having up against all
these tables we'll find out but oh my
God look at all the dead dresses it
looks like they have a trouble fighting
back against the catapult
but the vs. are fighting frog against a
cannibal because the ones that made it
in they can't defend himself against we
underestimated the dressers killed
everyone
one furniture versus another but who
will win that their divorces are dead a
yes a carpet for the table they had no
match for table but welded resid win or
will the tables in Chrome
they still have to fight against
catapult the catapult have repeatedly
turned back with it are still some
fragrance no there are not
there are no along dresser they said no
change the Crescent moving in from there
right but will they make it they are
dying back
[Music]
has changed no longer about nations
ideologies presence today
it's an endless series of proxy battles
fought by mercenaries machines war and
its consumption of life has become a
well-oiled machine
it's tabled a stable version threat but
the battle is not yet won too many
tables
that's too many of funk doors until like
Chuck Norris is still alive then he's
breaking the present left and right
my God my God he's older frog again not
yelling but a that's right Oh a random
you just hit your Torre quick still
alive another random suit
piranha bait
doctor is killing us Jack interview
these questions the table
[Music]
Oh table come on
the battle is over the last table takes
its last breath and the winner is check